[Musica]
ti senti un fallito
è un problema questo è un problema
prima di dire qui su questo palco
qualche sera fa io e solito vado in
camera mia a sviluppare tra detto primo
presentatore e sviluppo codici anche per
divertimento per rilassarmi e riflettevo
a con tutto inizio circa
cinque anni fa quando ben 13 anni
neanche 14 perché tutto iniziò un anno
prima mi ricordo ogni giorno dopo dice
un quarto io andavo in biblioteca della
mia scuola liceo classico e tavoli 1 ora
aspettano mia sorella per mentre le
usciva da scuola io sviluppavo codice
per un progetto
era un progetto che mi ero stesso a
questo progetto mi piaceva assai ed ero
così fuori il salto supportato al
termine che ogni giorno ero lì da solo
con neopor tattica ma c'è un particolare
lo schermo del portatile che io portavo
sempre con me quando la privo in
biblioteca e rapino di scritte rosse
errore errore errore serve errori non
ero proprio brava a fare quello che
volevo fare davvero
solo che avevo questo sogno ed ero così
testardo e volevo perseverare in questa
direzione nel frattempo per ogni giorno
i miei amici mi tiravano dopo scura
dicendo oggi non biblioteca oggi andiamo
al parco gen chiamo al mare oggi andiamo
a divertirci io ogni volta no sia perché
avevo aspettato di casa della sia perché
avevo questo obiettivo in testa da
portare a termine per band 24 mesi
quindi ben due anni di scuola io facevo
questo e non ci riuscivo per niente era
era un fallimento questa variante due
anni buttati qua anzi investiti in
questo processo
ogni giorno dopo la scuola un certo
punto mia madre viene vicino a me mi
dice loris e ma sei sicuro che tutto
questo impegno tutta questa stanchezza
di porterà qualcosa perché comunque non
voglio che ti stai così tanto qua dietro
qualcosa che forse
non avrà risultati li ho fatto una
scelta o mollo o faccio un cambiamento
ho iniziato impostare la mia vita come
se fosse una sfida continua gli studi
ieri mirarti giorno dopo giorno un
piccolo step alla volta neanche 10 per
cento neanche l'un per cento
solamente svegliarsi un pochino prima
solamente andasse a dormire andare a
dormire un pochino prima solamente fare
un pò una linea di codice fatta bene era
un risultato da lì nei prossimi 36 mesi
è tutto cambiato sono arrivato ad oggi
ho iniziato a impostare la disciplina la
mia forma mentis iniziare diano ai
ristoranti novali a noi partner no alle
feste e si invece a lavorare in un certo
modo a dormire di più assessore meglio a
studiare la programmazione un certo modo
per capire veramente come devo fare
certe cose è presente un pochino di
costanza tutto me mai fallito mai
mangiate fare idee per me tutti i giorni
tante tante volte che chi chi rimarrebbe
costante in questa direzione a cui ogni
volta a fallire il giorno dopo giorno e
nonostante questo rimane sempre lì
davanti a questo schermo a continuare a
riprovarci
è difficile essere costanti nel
fallimento e pensereste che invece è
facile avere successo deve sempre essere
costanti a dovere sempre non risultati
sempre successi dopo successi la
costanza è davvero difficile essere
quest'anno il fallimento è successo e
tanto complicato quindi ho messo
costanza nel fallire e nei successi pico
risultati non mi adattavo continua a
crescere per chi vuole sempre avere di
meglio lo sempre migliorare i loro studi
ieri se il giro restyle ha fatto una
pagina fatta bene di codice oggi dovevo
fare due domani 3
dopo arrivato questo
loris apre questa azienda
la cina chiede cui oggi sono
proprietario raggiungiamo migliaia di
utenti in italia e c'è un particolare
mia madre né watt e ritorno per 36 mesi
quindi oggi e mi dice
se hai fatto hai vinto investigherà sei
mesi io pensavo che non ce la facevo
perché avevo paura dei fatti stanno a
troppo invece vinto e il testardo ce
l'hai fatta mi ha detto adesso ti senti
pronto e capace di dire no sempre a
tutti quelle feste radiali a rimane
sempre da solo a casa per lavora su
questo progetto ad uscire è stato si va
dall ufficio alle nove di sera e dieci
di sera dal mio ufficio che abbiamo
accendo di saleh camminare vedere i due
compagni su lungomare a salerno e mentre
mangiano al ristorante mentre si
divertono e tu continui dritto verso la
macchina per tornare a casa e continua a
lavorare non è davvero facile e c'è un
dettaglio per fare tutto questo oltre a
decimi alla costanza il coraggio
perché bisogna essere coraggiosi per
andare controcorrente gesti coraggiosi
per vestirsi diversamente che pensa
diversamente per andare contro idee
degli altri per fare ciò che altri non
vogliono fare perché può anche essere
benché sia di fare una cosa come tutti
quanti potete farlo essere normale come
gli altri quindi vestiti come gli altri
fai quel che fanno gli altri vedevano
gli altri fai ciò che fanno gli altri
pensa come pensano gli altri scegli
lavoro come aveva fatto anche gli altri
scegli quello che gli altri scelgono è
facilissimo opre fa differenza
sì differente
chiuso di per oggi per fare questo
perché la vita non è semplice è per
essere coraggiosi c'è bisogno di
passione e
per avere una vita ricca di passioni
bisogno di coraggio perché senza il
coraggio non esisterebbe riccardo
camarda tommaso ceccato arianna polsi lo
sa bach a saldo per riserve nessuno di
queste persone se non avesse avuto il
coraggio di arrivare fino a qui oggi
davanti ostacoli fallimenti errori porte
chiuse in faccia
no notti in bianco e tanti tanti
fallimenti c'è bisogno di coraggio per
fare certe scelte
il mondo di oggi ha bisogno di questo di
coraggiosi di giorni coraggiosi che
facciano che riescono a fare quello che
hanno internamente molte volte diciamo
di essi coraggioso ha seguito sogno
a volte i sogni questo cosa che ci
influenza o cosa che abbiamo signori e
che cosa dobbiamo fare
ma il vero sogno è quello che ci ha
detto che a volte ma incrociamo ad
esprimere quello il vero sogno che molti
non sono coral non hanno il coraggio di
est 10 mostrare di cacciare all'esterno
di far vedere a tutti di parlarne
sì ne abbiamo e coraggiosi in questo
paese in questo mondo in questo mondo
così complesso competitivo ricco di
aziende e di offerte di domande di
colleghi di tante persone che possono
far ciò che quello che facciamo noi
ma non tutti possono essere coraggiosi e
questo importo fino a fino a quello che
adesso sono oggi e questa caratteristica
essere coraggiosi di andare
controcorrente dire no mamma perché ho
un sogno che non è quello di oggi non è
ok se oggi non ottengo questo risultato
allora va bene un sogno che potrebbe
dopo dieci anni dopo cinque anni avevo
quella quell'obiettivo
e normale che quando invece andando nei
questi cinque anni vide solamente
fallimento è difficile di rocca che la
potrei fare perché nessuno vede quello
che tu mi tra cinque anni
ci voleva coraggio
e voglio che anche voi abbiate coraggio
anche voi che tutti voi giovani che
ascolterete dovete avere coraggio di non
seguire mente il vostro sogno è andare
oltre posto sogno perché è vero questo
sogno e quello che se qua dentro
ecco che c'è qua dentro non tutti
riescono a mostrarlo riescono
a parlarne a tutti all'esterno è
complicato
a me senso di coraggiosi
il successo non è mai definitivo mai mai
neanche il fallimento però è fatale
neanche definitio l'unica cosa che conta
è il coraggio di continuare verso il
successo e verso il fallimento
questo lo dicevo in cui a 12 da winston
churchill
grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]